So, da bin ich wieder.
Hat ein bisschen länger gedauert.
Ich war noch wählen.
Falsch, Stelz.
Hab ich ganz vergessen,
dass das heute ist.
Riesen Zettel, Leute, ey.
Riesenzettel, ey.
Ich hab da überhaupt nicht durchgeblickt.
Moin.
Mach schon mal hier das nass an.
Aber bei den Wahlzetteln
soll echt mal einer durchblicken, ey.
Ich hab drei Stück gekriegt.
Ein kleiner, ein mittlerer und ein großer.
0 durchgeblickt aller
ob moment jetzt habe ich die vm angemacht ist falsch muss meine mini pc
einschalten
Oh, hört ihr das?
Ne, jetzt kann man es nicht hören.
Die Festplatte macht ein ganz merkwürdiges Geräusch gerade.
Also die geschuckte Festplatte im Nass, die hat gerade ein ganz merkwürdiges Geräusch gemacht.
Äh, warum ist denn mein Logitech?
Konntest du das Nass von U4 noch zurückschicken?
Ne, ich habe es absichtlich nicht zurückschickt.
Ich habe 30 Tage Zeit.
Das kriegt der Max dann
Die bessere Version
Und die andere, die behalte ich hier zum Basteln
Ich schick nix zurück
Ich hab jetzt
Drei nasse
Schüppelnass
Aber eins davon kriegt wie gesagt der Max dann
So
Da sind wir. Mal gucken, ob es noch wieder Package-Updates gibt.
Arch Linux, by the way.
Natürlich nicht. Okay.
Ich höre mich noch schlimmer an als vorhin.
Tja.
Ich war wählen.
Das hat mich schon wieder komplett verwirrt.
Die großen, riesen Wahlzettel.
Und jetzt war ich noch einmal hier um Main rum.
Spazieren.
Und dabei läuft immer richtig die Nase.
Aber bis jetzt eigentlich schon besser.
Also ist nicht schlimmer, hört sich vielleicht nur schlimmer an.
Moin, schmoll, Access Point.
So
Dann locken wir uns mal schnell
Huch, falsche Kiste
Dann locken wir uns mal schnell auf dem Nass ein
Hier
Also die Festplatte
Die baue ich jetzt mal aus
Die andere
Sonst bin ich
Verwirrt
Wenn da zu viele Platten drin sind
HDD ist nämlich die 2TB
Die brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht
Einmal erstmal Proxmox aufmachen
Was ist denn das?
Warum hat das hier so ein komisches
Was? Private Tab?
Warum hab ich
Ah, okay, whatever, keine Ahnung
Zwei Punkt
Den hier, da müssen wir uns einloggen
Proxmox
Ups, ich hab mich vertippt
Jetzt habe ich schon so ein extrem komplexes Passwort.
So, also hier haben wir unseren Open Media Vault.
Den starten wir gleich.
Erstmal, ich muss erstmal ein bisschen was vorbereiten hier.
Unmount.
HDD.
Weg damit.
Oder wie sagt man, was muss man da?
Zpool Export.
Sagt man da, ne?
Genau, dann verschwindet nämlich alles.
So, und jetzt.
start und ja
nicht starten
sondern jetzt muss man die ganze festplatten noch entschlüsseln das nord exist
Zpool
Status, wo ist mein ZFS-Pool hin?
im Import
schuckt.
Damit ich das noch richtig schreibe.
Okay.
Ah ja, hier sind wir.
Wie konnte man mit ZFS
nochmal checken, ob man Verschlüsselung anhat?
ZFS get.
Encryption
Genau
Save
Okay
Na es läuft
Okay gut hier passt es ist verschlüsselt
Dann testen wir gerade noch mal kurz
Mit der Festplatte ob alles okay ist
Soweit
Ob die
Ordentlich
Ja passt
Ja, okay
Gut, Funst
Also 247
Da frage ich mich jetzt gerade
Was ist, wenn ich die Block Size runter mache
Auf 4K
Oder was hat denn
Eine Magnetfestplatte für eine Sektor Size
4K oder 512 Byte
Das kann ich mir nicht wirklich vorstellen
Gerade
Was auch immer das hier für ein Mist anzeigt
Das muss irgendein Caching sein.
Äh.
Das kann nicht sein.
Nie im Leben macht die 733 MB die Sekunde.
Die Festplatte lügt, Leute.
Das macht irgendeine ZFS-Magic unter der Haube
Garantiert
Achso, ja, ich weiß, woran das liegt
Wahrscheinlich, weil das in Cache reinpasst
Könnte ich mir vorstellen
Na gut
Dann
Machen wir mit OpenSSL
OpenSSL Random
Ging das so?
Und jetzt pipen wir das mal hier irgendwie hin
Blub.bin
Uptinstall.pv
So, und dann kann es losgehen
Mal kurz gucken, wie schnell die Festplatte wirklich ist, wenn man da random Zeug drauf schreibt
Okay, das war zu wenig
Wäre schon besser
Ja, das ist doch dann in der Tat etwas realistischer
Wenn man random Sachen auf die Festplatte schreibt
200, 230, 240 MB.
Ja, und jetzt
schwankt das ein bisschen.
Okay, Leute, wir machen das so.
Ich lasse das hier gerade mal kurz laufen.
Ich muss mir noch schnell was zu trinken holen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Da können wir nämlich mal sehen, ob die Sache konstant bleibt.
Gleich wieder am Start.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, da bin ich.
Also das scheint so zu passen.
Guck mal, da hat er jetzt schon
22 Gig geschrieben.
gleich wieder nach Mainz Leute
gerade was checken
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Okay, so.
wieder am start also was macht meine festplatte die schreibt immer noch so mit 200 irgend etwas
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Jetzt aber. Ich muss gerade
im zweiten Display noch was
fertig gucken. Hoch, ist das? Geh weg.
So.
Also, folgendes.
Also, die Festplatte scheint ja wirklich
tatsächlich ganz ordentlich zu funktionieren.
So, also folgendes will ich heute ausprobieren.
Und zwar, guckt mal, ich habe hier ja einen Open Media Vault laufen.
Ich starte den nochmal, da können wir uns das gleich zusammen angucken.
Chatkill, warum startet der Open Media Vault nicht?
Was hat der?
Ah, Directory does not exist.
Ich habe den Kram ja gerade gelöscht.
Alter, ich dab.
Okay, Moment, ich zeige euch das gleich nochmal.
Hier, Kekkel, Kekkel, meine Benamung, Leute.
Meine Benahmung ist wieder wirklich exzellent.
Kekkel Cash.
Kekkel HDD Kekkel Cash.
Jetzt weiß man, weiß man gleich Bescheid, oder?
Jetzt habe ich irgendwie gerade mein Chatfenster zu groß gemacht.
Ja, also, das war jetzt nicht so schlau, meine Sachen so zu benennen.
So.
Digga, hier auch voll auf dem Go.
Own your shit train.
Was?
Own your shit?
Du meinst keine Cloud-Sachen oder was?
Ein iPod.
Moment, es gibt noch iPods?
I can't wait.
Na gut, warum soll es die auch nicht mehr geben?
So, dann lösche ich den Kram jetzt hier nochmal kurz.
Hier, äh, Remove.
Wie ging das nochmal, das Edit?
Moment, Moment.
Nur, dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Man kann das...
Pass...
Thruen?
Ja doch, hier. Genau.
Also, ich muss das mal kurz
removen.
Und jetzt müssen wir nochmal was anlegen.
Und zwar gehen wir mal kurz auf die Festplatte.
Schuckt, Save.
Dann haben wir hier MKDOMV.
Das reichen wir durch
Und dann machen wir noch auf dem
SSD-Rate
Machen wir noch
Das SSD-Rate ist unter
Slashwork safe
MKDier
Hier lösche ich das Ding mal
OMV
Das wird jetzt da reingemountet
Wir vergleichen das jetzt nochmal
Mit der VM
Bevor wir das mit dem LXC-Container machen
Nur dass wir nochmal so ein Baseline haben
Wie schnell das jetzt in der VM ist
also moment hier hier muss ich hin storage directory mappings also name
cash kommen wir nennen das jetzt mal halbwegs gescheit fahrt der fahrt zack
und jetzt noch hdd save omv so hier zack
okay gut jetzt haben wir den kram und jetzt können wir uns noch mal hier rein
mappen zu open media vault wird tofs directory mapping cache allow direct io jawoll
wunderbar und jetzt wird hier OFS
allow direct IO mapping HDD zack ok start
das naming ist top oder jetzt doch cache os user geworden
ja also ich habe ich habe jetzt hier hat mein setup hier meine windows kiste und
hier CacheOS. Das CacheOS läuft
auf dem Mini-PC, das Windows läuft
halt nach wie vor auf dem fetten Gaming-PC.
Aber ich bin jetzt auf
zweimal Hardware unterwegs.
2.52 ist es glaube ich
gewesen auf MediaWorld. Genau.
So, Storage.
Jetzt muss ich gerade nochmal was gucken,
dass das auch ordentlich funktioniert.
Schedule Tasks Reboot.
Wir müssen nicht Kekkel-HD mounten,
Wir müssen...
Wir müssen Cache mounten.
Safe.
Und wir müssen HDD mounten.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Vor allem, warum hab ich da eigentlich bitteschön MNT2 richtig hängen geblieben?
Aber es funktioniert.
So, dann machen wir das mal so hier.
Zack.
Safe.
Yes.
Und jetzt machen wir nochmal Reboot von Open Media Volt und dann sollte alles funktionieren.
Dann gucken wir mal, wie schnell es ist.
Also keine Streaming-VM, habe ich dich richtig verstanden? Ja.
Guck, das hier ist jetzt ein Beelink Mini PC SR7 mit einem Ryzen 7 7840 HS, 16 Threads, 8 Kerne,
5,14 Gigahertz.
Arm?
Nee, nix arm.
Das ist ein x86.
Das ist eine x86 Kiste.
Guck hier.
Rock CPU Info.
Bam.
Ein Authentic AMD, bitteschön.
Nicht irgendwie ein Fake AMD, ein richtig
echter Authentic AMD.
Ähm, ja.
Was nutzt du für die Bildschirmübertragung?
Ich übertrage den Bildschirm
nicht im klassischen Sinne.
Ich, äh, hab ne Capture-Karte.
Also ich hab jetzt da kein spezielles Software dafür, ne?
Ich mach das mit ner Capture-Karte.
Guck, das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Hier. OBS.
Hier im zweiten Desktop ist ein OBS im Fullscreen.
Und hier ist meine
Elgato Capture-Karte.
Und hat es als Input
den Mini-PC.
1080p.
240 Hertz.
und das ist halt einfach im Fullscreen,
deswegen fällt das nicht auf und das Gute ist
dadurch, dass es mit 240 Hertz
Captured und direkt in die
in die Elgato,
das ist eine PCI Express Elgato Karte
reingeht. Ne, die
Capture Card, die noch den Kommentator Zeit überlebt hat,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, die ist
deutlich neuer, die gab es damals
noch gar nicht, das ist Elgato
4K Pro, das ist auch die
einzige, glaube ich, die die haben,
die möglichst latency free oder mit wirklich sehr geringer latenz 1080p 240
hertz über über capturen kann darüber kannst du auch machen also keystrokes
maus ach so keystrokes und maus mache ich mit desk flow des flow hier einmal
auf der linux kiste und deskflow auf der windows kiste und das was jetzt passiert
ist ich habe einen shortcut ein makro makro shortcut wenn ich auf meiner
tastatur f2 drücke was der macht unter der haube ist der switch auf den zweiten
windows desktop und dann drückt er einen shortcut um mit deskflow die maus und
das Tattoo rüber zu geben. Guck,
das macht der Plus halt sehr schnell mit einem Makro.
Und so habe ich
quasi eine echte Hardware-Kiste
auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Das ist wie der Krücken-Setup.
Ist es aber das Beste, was es gibt?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das noch großartig
verbessern könnte.
Was richtig mega wäre,
wenn es
sowas wie Parsec
oder
eine gescheite Implementierung von
Nvidia Game Stream und so gebe,
mit der man das machen könnte.
Aber,
damit hatte ich ein Problem.
Damit hatte ich ein Problem.
Nee, nee, geht nicht.
Damit hatte ich Probleme.
Das habe ich ausprobiert.
Ich habe das mit Sunshine ausprobiert.
Mit Sunshine hatte ich Probleme mit Copy-Paste
und ich hatte Probleme mit dem Sound.
Auf deinem Gaming-PC Linux installiert,
direkt streamen. Ne, ne, das ist ja gerade der Witz
dabei. Erstens hat es eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte.
Zweitens will ich da
im Zweifelsfall auch mal was mit Anti-Cheat spielen.
Drittens will ich da mal einen anderen Krempel
verwenden, an den ich mich gewöhnt habe für Videoschnitt
und Thumbnails und sowas.
Ne, VNC kannst du vergessen.
VNC ist laggy as fuck.
Ne, ne, das ist nix. Ne, ne,
VNC ist nix.
VNC ist was, wenn du irgendwie
Remote mal ein bisschen GUI klicken
willst, aber nicht hier für sowas.
also probleme mit copy paste von linux auf windows und vice versa genau jetzt funktioniert
es zumindest zuverlässig in eine richtung die andere noch nicht so hundertprozentig
aber immerhin besser als wie es mit sunshine funktioniert hat so gehen wir mal aufs nass
drauf. Auf die NAS-VM.
Gucken wir mal, ob alles funktioniert.
Der hat gemountet, hat
gemountet. Ähm,
einloggen.
Also Audio hätte ich noch
eine andere Möglichkeit, aber das ist auch
eine Krücke. Audio könnte
ich auch noch
per analogem Audio-Ausgang
rausgehen.
aus dem mini pc in mein audio interface und müsste mir das dann hier irgendwie
wieder rein spielen aber dann dann hört ihr es nicht richtig und so was so wie
ich das jetzt hier habe ist deutlich praktischer ihr hört doch sound hier in
der vm oder das mal kurz ausprobieren
was meint ihr was die schnellste möglichkeit ist bei hörte das gelaber
aus meinem video einer bank in frankfurt hausverbot zu bekommen wohlgemerkt als
IT-Experte.
Ja, gut.
Das flutscht halt auch richtig gut, muss man sagen.
Hier mit...
Guck mal, ich hab kaum
CPU-Auslastung.
Dadurch, dass das hier alles mit der Grafikkarte decoded wird.
1080p
GPU-Decoding. Das ist halt nice auf der
Hardware-Linux-Kiste.
So.
Also, dann schauen wir doch mal,
wie schnell
ist denn heute die
Open-Media-Wall-NAS-Geschichte?
zack
äh, Max, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
hoffe ich mal, hu, nochmal Glück gehabt
Merger FS, okay, das geht
schon mal nicht, Data geht auch schon mal nicht
Exquisite, ah, ich
weiß, warum das nicht geht
weil ich ein Kack-Noob bin
weil ich glaube, ich erst
nochmal
erstmal wird hier alles CH moddet
so, und jetzt gucke ich nochmal, ob es jetzt funktioniert
Erstmal alles 7, 7, 7, 10.
Okay, ich habe irgendwas verkehrt gemacht.
Lass mal kurz ins Open Media Vault gucken, was ich hier verkackt habe.
Also, Services, Samba, läuft.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, so.
Ich bin gerade ein bisschen abgelenkt.
Zeug, was ich hier gerade im Bildschirm sehe.
Wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, ich wollte gucken, warum dieser Kram hier nicht funktioniert.
Also, Samba an sich ist eingeschaltet.
Storage.
ist auch an shared mein shared folder ist kaputt da gibt es kein data ordner
ja das wird es wahrscheinlich sein data gibt es nicht okay
MNT Data
und MNT 2 Data
Beste Benahmung wieder mal bei mir
hier am Start
Ich reboote nochmal
Ich habe ja eben die Laufwerke gelöscht, deswegen ging das nicht
Sollte schon eine Film-Musik-Streaming-Kiste werden, oder?
Was meinst du?
Ja, ja, mir geht's gut
Schön, dass du mal vorbeigeschaut hast
Sollte schon eine Musikfilming-Streaming-Kiste werden
Was meinst du?
Ach, Link vom Mini-PC
Okay
Beelink CR7
Ja, das Teil
Ist aber schon ein bisschen älter, wie man hier sieht
Also, da gibt es
Mit Vapor Chamber Kühlung. Aha.
Da gibt es mittlerweile schon neuere davon.
Die Kiste ist das.
So, hat es jetzt funktioniert hier?
Hast du dein Minis Forum direkt über deren Seite bestellt?
Ne, über Amazon.
Amazon? Nee, nee, oder? Warte mal.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nee, den neuesten Ugreen habe ich über die Ugreen-Webseite bestellt.
Minis Forum habe ich über Amazon bestellt.
Mir ist das Ziel noch nicht ganz klar.
Ja, das kann ich dir auch jetzt erst zeigen, wenn mein...
Wenn das Nass hier richtig...
Die Falsche ist richtig funktionieren.
Okay, Funst, alles klar
Alter, warum funst du das nicht
Also, das Ding ist folgendes
Kiyokun, moin
Ich hab mir eine VM gebaut
Mit Open Media Vault
Und hab dadurch die Laufwerke durchgereicht
Nicht die Laufwerke durchgereicht
Die Verzeichnisse durchgereicht
Und ich hab das letzte Mal festgestellt
Das ist relativ schnell mit der VM
Aber das ist jetzt nicht übertrieben schnell
Guck, ich kann es euch zeigen
Ich kopiere jetzt hier mal was über das Netzwerk rüber.
Und wir kommen hier auf ungefähr...
Warum ist das auf einmal so langsam?
Chat?
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Warum ist das auf einmal so langsam?
Okay.
Ich...
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Jetzt ist es schnell.
Whatever.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
So.
Also wir haben so ungefähr 950 MB bis 1 GB.
Die Sekunde kriegen wir da drüber.
Ja, das ist jetzt, das ist für 10 GB, für eine 10 GB Verbindung ist das okay.
Aber da geht noch mehr, ja.
Also man kann durchaus 1,1, 1,2 GB durchbekommen bei einer 10 GB Verbindung.
So und das will ich heute mal mit einem LXC-Container probieren.
Wir machen, wir, ähm,
wir stellen einen LXC-Container mit einem Debian drauf,
installieren uns selbst mal einen Samba-Server
und das alles Zeug drumherum.
NAS-Controller-Limit, was ist denn ein NAS-Controller?
Ja, und eigentlich will ich das Ganze noch mit MergerFS machen,
was aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht funktioniert.
Ähm, cannot be accessed,
Das muss ich mir jetzt gerade nochmal angucken, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Mal kurz hier gucken.
Storage.
Ne, wo war das hier?
Shares.
Is unavailable.
Warum?
Warum ist das unavailable?
Muss ich das jetzt verstehen?
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Okay, ich mach das nochmal kurz rückgängig.
Ich lösch den Kram hier einfach mal kurz.
Shared Folder kann man nicht mal löschen?
Okay, warum nicht?
Kann man nicht löschen?
Ähm.
Ah, weil
weil
Samba-Shares
noch existieren, ne?
Erstmal Samba-Share wegmachen.
So, zack.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen
Storage Shared Folder.
Okay.
Yes.
Moin.
Ja, ja. Wird's
geben auf YouTube. Ich muss erst mal
im Kopf wieder klarkommen.
Dann gibt es auch was auf YouTube.
Was ist das
Bandbreitenlimit der NAS-Hardware? Nur mal
so zum Verständnis. Also das
hat eine 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte.
Guck hier, pass auf.
IPerf
Zeige ich dir.
Hier, Terminal, CD, Desktop.
Iperf
3 minus C
1 und 2
Also 9,
ja, bisschen schwankend
bisschen auch schwankend, hä?
Ziemlich, ziemlich
schwankend
Schwankchamp
Rockchamp, ja
Massive-Pock-Champ.
Welchen RAM brauche ich für das Minisform?
Das ist ein SO-DEM.
Ja, unterstützt kein ECC.
Nur das Pro, die Pro-Variante unterstützt ECC.
Aber die Pro-Variante würde ich Abstand von halten.
Die hat angeblich Probleme mit dem SATA-Controller.
Und die braucht auch mehr Strom im Idle.
Also eher nicht das, was man haben will.
So, also in die eine Richtung kriegen wir so um die 9 Gigabit.
Und in die andere Richtung kriegen wir so, ja, auch in dem Dreh.
Also mehr oder weniger das Gleiche, würde ich sagen.
In beide, ja, in beide Richtungen ungefähr 9 Gigabit.
Was mich jetzt aber wundert, ist, warum das so schwankt.
Chat, ich habe eine Idee.
Wollen wir nochmal einen neuen Netzwerktreiber kompilieren?
Ich habe damit schon mal angefangen, aber habe es noch nicht durchgezogen.
Aber ich habe gesehen, wir können mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir das schon noch ein bisschen schneller.
hier guck, hier habe ich auch schon die Debian Packages
und so mal testweise gebaut
wobei ich da nicht sicher bin, ob das
auch ordentlich funktioniert hat, deswegen mache ich
das jetzt mal wieder alles
weg, wir können
nochmal einen neuen Netzwerktreiber
kompilieren, weil guckt mal
der Netzwerktreiber, den ich habe
ist Version 11.015
und wenn man bei Realtek
guckt auf der Webseite
dann wird man feststellen
es gibt jetzt einen Netzwerktreiber
für
11.016
also ich habe 11.015
und das ist 11.016
wer sich jetzt fragt
alter Max, warum überhaupt
eigene Netzwerktreiber und so kompilieren
das Problem ist
wenn ich den offiziellen Linux-Netzwerktreiber benutze
da ist die Performance
in VMs
ziemlich verbuggt
man kriegt genau die Hälfte von 10 Gigabit und das finde ich ziemlich
sadge
deswegen benutze ich den offiziellen
Netzwerktreiber vom Hersteller
So das können wir eigentlich nochmal machen
Oh das war jetzt nicht so clever das ich das gelöscht hab
dass ich den alten gelöscht habe
ich hätte den alten eigentlich dass der alte Netzwerk 3 war ein Sternenbehalten
er zählt weiß irgendjemand ob man
denn installiertes Debian Package
extrahieren kann also das irgendwie ist es sich aus kopieren
extrakt installiert
Package
weil ich hab das ich hab's ja
ich hab's ja installiert
Also ich würde gerne dieses Debian-Package hier, was ich installiert habe, würde ich mir gerne mal irgendwo temporär speichern.
Upt-Save-Deb-Package. Geht das?
Upt-Get-Download-Only.
Michael, 50 Billiarden.
Moin, schön, dass du da bist.
Oh, ganz schön groß gerade.
Where to store Dapp-Files?
Varkash Archives.
Okay, da irgendwo ist es angeblich.
Oder auch nicht.
äh
where does
upstore
avion packages
ok, anscheinend ist es nicht mehr da
das ist natürlich ziemlich doof
das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt aninstall
egal, chat, ihr dürft euch aussuchen
wollen wir den neuesten Netzwerk-Dreiber
mal ausprobieren und gucken
ob es dann noch mal bessere Bandbreite gibt
Ja, oder?
Wollen wir schon
Repackage
Probieren wir das einfach mal aus
Also, hier habe ich den Ordner mit dem
Treiber drin
Wir könnten theoretisch einfach
Warte mal, Git log
Also was ich, ok, Moment
CP
Ich hab mir den doch schon mal kopiert
Hier, oder? Da genau
Hier, ich hab den alten, alles klar
Ich hab den alten sogar noch hier, alles gut
Dann passt das
So, Gitlog, was haben wir denn hier?
Der Fernandes
Royas
Der war's
Äh
R81
Ne, 8127DKMS
So und hier habe ich auch ein bisschen
dran rum gebastelt
Red Rhythm
Ich wollte eigentlich Readme oder so schreiben
Okay, hier habe ich die Sachen nämlich schon
Source Code mäßig gepatcht mit dem neuesten
Machen wir mal Make Clean
Den Kram schon gepatcht mit dem neuesten
Realtek Treibern
Hier liegt
quasi das neueste Realtek Zeug
Weiß gar nicht, ob man das irgendwie da drin sieht
grep 11.016
sieht man das hier irgendwo vielleicht?
Genau, RTL Version 11.016
Hier.
Also, das heißt im Endeffekt
ich kann jetzt einfach ein Debian Package
Moment, wie macht man das nochmal?
R8127
DKMS GitHub
Guthub
Moment, wir gucken einfach, geht.
Remote minus V, hier.
Da ist es doch.
Da ist doch das Repo.
Okay, der hat vor 5 Monaten was gemacht, da war die Sache noch nicht drin.
Aber hier steht, wie man es baut.
Building Package.
Genau, erstmal muss man sagen, up BuildDev und jetzt dpkg-build-package-b no sign.
Genau, und jetzt haben wir hier den neuesten Treiber am Start.
Okay, wir können nochmal kurz gucken, ob es irgendwelche neuen Kernel-Parameter oder so gibt oder Modul-Parameter gibt, die man tweaken kann.
ähm,
Make,
gucken wir mal ins Make-File.
Lass uns mal das Make-File
diffen. Das aktuelle
Make-File von,
ähm,
äh, wie ging das?
Head-3?
Ach, keine Ahnung mehr.
Ähm,
das Make-File,
Make-File von ihm.
No such file
oder... Ach, ich kack noob.
Ja, natürlich
hat sich das nicht geändert.
Weil das war ja gar nicht
committed.
Hab ich das
vielleicht...
Das hab ich nie committed.
ich bin hochgradig verwirrt.
No such file or directory?
Macht doch eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ging das nicht so?
Konnte man nicht so zwei Sachen diffen?
Moment.
Git diff.
Na gut, wir können auch einfach sagen,
git log auf
source make file.
Minus 1, minus p.
Okay.
Okay, hier.
Also, wakeonlan
support
unterscheidet sich.
Das wakeonlan habe ich ausgeschaltet.
Das ist auch Absicht. Will ich ja auch nicht haben.
Oder? Ist WakeOnLan ausgeschaltet?
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Woll.
Ach, DisableWollSupport.
Okay.
Ja, sonst hat sich da nichts...
Und ASPM ist No.
Ja, okay, passt schon.
Na gut.
Dann installieren wir mal den neuesten Treiber.
apt install, das hatten wir übrigens heute
morgen, heute morgen meint jemand
man kann mit apt keine lokalen Packages
installieren oder irgendwie sowas, man muss das mit dpg
ag machen, guck
das geht
apt install, jetzt kann man einfach
sagen hier .slash
r81 bla bla bla
hier
dkms.deb
und schon hat man
ein lokales Debian-Package installiert.
Okay.
Jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich noch mal rebooten.
Geht nicht anders.
Weil, wenn wir nicht rebooten, haben wir nicht die neuesten Netzwerktreiber.
Reboot.
Schauen wir mal.
Der wird garantiert noch nicht wieder da sein.
Chat, kann es sein, dass das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht rebootet?
Hängt der irgendwie beim Rebooten? Kann das sein?
Upt, Install
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich keine
QEMO Guest Agents
installiert habe
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein
Machen wir den hier aus
Reboot
Ah, jetzt, okay
Da ist der Open Media Vault hing
Jetzt ist er auch hier aus
Guckt
Und dann gucken wir gleich mal wie schnell er ist
Mit dem neuen Netzwerktreiber
Ich hoffe der kommt jetzt überhaupt wieder hoch
und hat eine IP und alles.
Ah, da ist er wieder. Sehr gut.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen Schiss gehabt, dass der jetzt nicht mehr hochkommt
mit der neuesten Netzwerk-Treiber-Version.
So.
016.
Kann man mit Mod-Info
die Version sehen?
Soll das so etwas werden wie ein Nvidia Shield?
Ne, das soll ein ganz normales
Nass werden.
MonkaS, was zum
Treiber-Version?
Hier.
Was bin ich hier eigentlich sehend gerade?
Sind das Parameter, die man quasi übergeben kann, oder wie?
Sind das Modulparameter, die ich irgendwie übergeben kann?
Und woher weiß ich, welche Parameter da jetzt gesetzt waren?
Warum nicht direkt Open Media Vault auf die Kiste?
Weil ich eigentlich hauptsächlich damit Sachen virtualisieren will.
Da kommen hauptsächlich vor allem so Containerkram drauf.
Aber nebenbei, so Netzwerkshare ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen
Dass das mit Open Media Vault Overkill ist
Das war auch nur so ein Test
Das letzte Mal
Ob das eine gute Idee ist, sei mal dahingestellt
Ja aber Virtualisierung in OMV suckt
So gucken wir mal ob das jetzt schneller ist
Hm, ne
Ehrlich gesagt, absolut kein Unterschied, oder?
Aber warum schwankt der denn so doof?
Kann mir das jemand erklären, warum der so dumm schwankt?
Äh, what the f...
Jet, was jetzt?
Alter!
Ähm
Wisst ihr was?
Das mit dem neuen Netzwerktreiber
War vielleicht doch nicht so eine gute Idee, oder?
The fuck?
Was ist das denn?
Äh.
Also das ist in der Tat jetzt recht weird.
Was ist das denn?
Moment, Moment, sehe ich das jetzt richtig, dass das mit der neuesten Netzwerktreiber-Version deutlich schlechter geworden ist?
auf topik woran kann es liegen dass mich mit dolphin nicht über web darf auf meine
mailbox storage verbinden kann kommt es auch keine ahnung was dolphin treibt
Keine Ahnung
Vielleicht musst du irgendwelche Zusatzpakete installieren
Gerade für den File Manager gibt es
tatsächlich Zusatzpakete
Ähm
Was ist das denn für ein Shit
Okay Chat
Ich hab da mal
eine Frage an euch
Mod-Info
Guck mal, hier kann man ja so viel Zeug einstellen
Ich frag einfach mal
ChatGPT
Kann man der Parameter
übergeben?
Zeig die Kernel-Modul-Parameter des Treibers an
Damit kannst du das Verhalten des Realtests
zur Laufzeit konfigurieren
Ja, das
Param gleich Value
Aha
EEE enable gleich 0
ok
Und woher weiß ich, was für Parameter
jetzt default sind?
Auf was für einem Wert stehen denn diese Parameter
jetzt defaultmäßig?
Ja, ich weiß,
ASPM muss aus, dass das schnell ist.
Sonst frunzt das nicht.
Warte mal.
LSPCI.
Moment.
ASPM.
Check LSPCI.
Minus IASPM.
Äh.
Was ist das Problem jetzt?
keine ahnung wie vor drei wo sehe ich denn jetzt mein netzwerk hat network
network realtec realtec der realtec da ist immer so seht ihr hier irgendwas von
ASPM bei dem Realtek Controller.
Das ist immer abartig. Monka W. War da echt wo? Wall of Text? Wo war da ASPM?
ASPM, hier.
ASPM L1 enabled.
Sollte eigentlich
nicht der Fall sein.
Ich hab doch
explizit gesagt, hier, guck dir mal.
Source
Makefile.
Da steht explizit
Config ASPM
Yes steht da drin.
Warum denn das?
Das soll auf
Disabled sein
So und
EEE können wir auch mal gerade
Das können wir auch mal gleich auf No stellen
Okay
Also sprich
Debian
Nochmal kurz hier
Package bauen
Machen wir erstmal
Make clean
So, und jetzt hier
Hier haben wir die Debian Packages
Install
Ja, ich weiß
Angeblich ist das
Das ist nicht schon installiert
Debian lügt
R81DKMS
Uninstall, jawohl
Und jetzt gleich nochmal installieren
Ja, das ist total verbuggt mit dem Power Management
Was machen wir heute mit der Netzwerkkarte?
Eigentlich wollte ich nur den neuesten Netzwerkkartentreiber installieren
Und hab festgestellt, WTF, auf einmal ist es super langsam
Und das liegt daran, dass ich Power Management irgendwie aktiviert hab
Was überhaupt nicht mein Plan war
Reboot
Wollen wir mal pingen, bis er wieder da ist
Pass mal auf, wahrscheinlich ist der Open Media Vault
Jetzt auch gleich viel schneller mit der neuen Netzwerktreiber Version
Oh, ich muss mal was trinken
Ah!
Aha, da ist er wieder.
Ja, ich habe heute genug getrunken.
Okay, also.
Mod.
Mod-Info.
Ich checke halt immer noch nicht genau,
wie ich jetzt hier sehen kann.
Wie kann ich denn
die Default
der Parameter sehen?
Es gibt mehrere Wege.
Du lügst.
Es lügt, Leute.
Es lügt.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Aber das hier ist schon mal
Classic, ja.
Das hier ist schon mal ein guter Hinweis, zumindest.
Ja.
Okay, äh...
Funzt du nicht. Also das, das, das funzt nicht.
Im Treiber-Source, ja, klar.
Existiert nicht.
You are absolutely right.
Alter, laber nicht!
Natürlich ist das geladen.
Das schwätzt.
Das schwätzt einfach nur dumm rum.
Guck, das ist einfach nur dumm.
Okay, jetzt.
Iperf minus S.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Ah.
Leute, das ist besser jetzt als vorher.
Guck mal.
Seht ihr das?
Jetzt ist es konstant.
Konstant über 9.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich hab nix gesagt
Na gut, es kommt ungefähr aufs gleiche raus
Ja gut, dann schwankt das halt ein bisschen
Ey, das ist doch eine Schrott-Werzwerkade, Alter
Okay, scheiß drauf
Wenn ich damit jetzt noch ewig rummache, dann hört
ja keiner mehr auf
Ist im Prinzip das gleiche
Da dreh ich durch, wenn ich das noch länger
länger. So, gibt es noch irgendwas?
Einmal gucke ich jetzt noch.
Gibt es hier noch irgendwelche Dinger
im Makefile,
was so aussieht, als könnte es die Performance
verbessern? Enable
Gigalight. Sollte egal sein.
Enable Rx Package
Fragment. Braucht Page Reuse.
Brauchen wir wahrscheinlich auch alles nicht.
Double WLAN brauchen wir nichts.
Multi Disable
MSIX Vector.
Nee, nee, nee.
Auch nicht
Also
Multiple TXQ
TX no close
Das ist default
Ne ne ne Jumbo Frames mach ich nicht
Das mach ich nicht
Config Downspeed
Also ich glaube viel mehr können wir da nicht dran
Können wir da nicht
Können wir da viel mehr nicht dran drehen
Okay dann lassen wir das jetzt so
Warum
Na gut.
Drei nass.
Bitte schön, drei nass.
So, jetzt haben wir hier den Kram.
gestartet.
Jetzt können wir OMV starten.
Und nochmal gucken, wie es aussieht.
Äh, hallo?
Ah, ich sollte Open Media Vault
vielleicht auch starten, bevor ich mich versuche
einzuloggen.
Ich glaube, das wäre ziemlich high IQ.
Das hätte was, oder?
Wäre nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Zack.
Wie jetzt?
Natürlich bist du da.
So.
Services, Shares.
ok jetzt kann ich den merger fs hier nochmal noch marschieren shared folders
Yes
Select File System
Everybody
Read Write, Save
Und jetzt Services, SSH
Shares
Add
Save
Und jetzt
Apply
So, und jetzt können wir nochmal gucken, wie schnell das jetzt mit der neuen Netzwerkart ist
Ah, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Wir machen mal ein IPerf
Uptinstall IPerf 3
in der VM.
Äh, no.
IPerf 3 minus S.
Schauen wir mal hier
auf die 2.
Das ist in der Tat ein bisschen
langsamer in der VM.
Ein Ticken.
Ticken langsamer, aber eins muss man sagen,
deutlich konstanter
in der VM.
Naja, gut, hier schwankt's
auch.
Schwankt genauso.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Hier.
Hallo?
Okay, wir probieren es aus.
Hier drauf einmal kopieren.
Hier drauf kopieren.
Mal gucken, wie schnell es jetzt ist.
Das braucht immer ein bisschen.
Das muss irgendwie gefühlt immer erstmal aufwärmen,
bis das anfängt richtig rüber zu...
bis das ordentlich rüberflutscht.
Okay, Geschwindigkeit ist jetzt
eigentlich kein Unterschied,
würde ich sagen.
Kein Unterschied.
Ist genauso schnell wie vorher.
Das ist der Samba-Treiber von Windows, der sagt, okay, wir können das ausprobieren.
Ich habe hier noch meinen Unraid.
Das hat auch eine 10-Gegner-Zweckkarte.
Machen wir mal von Linux auf Linux, hä?
Okay, und jetzt gehen wir mal hier hin.
Ups, äh.
Gehen wir nach MergerFS.
Das braucht auch immer ein bisschen, bis das anläuft.
Warum ist das jetzt so langsam?
Hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, es ist schneller.
Ah, es wird auch noch schneller. Okay.
Okay, genauso schnell.
Also wenn es in den Cache schreibt, ist es immer noch genauso schnell.
Sogar ein Ticken schneller. Guck mal.
Welche SMB-Version wird ihr? 2 oder 3?
Okay, also so schnell sind wir in der VM.
Ne, NFS juckt mich nicht.
NFS benutze ich nicht.
NFS bringt mir nichts, wenn ich Windows Backups und so machen will.
Wir können jetzt noch einmal hier gucken.
Machen wir mal hier.
IPerf.
Root at Unraid.
Ne, Moment.
Sekunde, Leute. Ich muss mal kurz nach
meiner IP suchen.
Aha, okay.
Hab's.
148.
Ach so.
Ach du Scheiße. Keine Ahnung.
Hoffentlich habe ich da noch ein IPerf drauf laufen.
Ah, habe ich.
Okay, von der 4M auf
mein Android sind es auch nur 8,5
8,8
Irgendwas
Reverse
Seit wann kann Windows NFS?
Also mit irgendwelchem
Aber hier schwankt es auch, guckt
Mit irgendwelchem Zusatzkram, der nicht so richtig stable ist
wahrscheinlich
iPerf
Ne, der schwankt einfach
Guck mal, das juckt die nicht
Die Netzwerkverbindung
Das ist jetzt egal, ob ich das zwischen Windows und Linux
Und so mach, das ist
Immer
Es gleiche
Achso, dass der SMB-Treiber sagt
Ja gut, das kann sein, aber
Gut, damit müssen wir leben
Ich will es ja von Windows aus benutzen.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass das Samba-Treiber Schrott ist.
Der Switch.
NFS? Okay.
Wie gut ist nfs windows?
okay
Moment, wie du nfs Windows mounten kannst
Guide zu den Mounten von Unix-Klienten mit Windows nfs
Die Schwankung kann doch an der Temperatur der CPU liegen.
Ne, die CPU-Temperatur ist übrigens auch relativ gut.
Z minus I.
CTL.
Ja, die ist gut.
Wir können auch mal hier rüber kopieren.
Und dann uns mal die CPU-Entwicklung angucken.
gleich gleich dreht er gleich dreht er der hoch
noch macht mein lüfter gar nichts großartig also einer cpu temperatur liegt es nicht leute
Der Lüfter
Der Lüfter dreht sogar kaum hoch
Der Lüfter ist nahezu
Nahezu aus gerade
Ich glaube bei 70 Grad dreht der Lüfter
Ein bisschen hoch
Müssen wir mal abwarten, lass mal kurz gucken
Ich halt mal kurz mein Ohr dran
Ne, der Lüfter macht immer noch nichts
Ne, das stört den nicht.
Jetzt hat der Lüfter minimal hochgedreht.
Aber das ist nahezu unhörbar, das Nasse immer noch.
Ich weiß nicht, ab wann der Lüfter richtig krass hochdreht.
Wahrscheinlich 70 Grad oder so.
Bis dahin ist die Copy-Aktion aber hier durch.
Guck mal, jetzt gibt er richtig Gas.
Oder auch nicht.
Ja.
Keine Chance.
Der wird anscheinend nicht.
Jetzt.
Ne, Leute.
Juckt ihr nicht.
Jetzt dreht der Lüfter hoch.
Jetzt hat er richtig hoch gedreht, der Lüfter.
Weiß nicht, ihr hört es?
Hört ihr es im Hintergrund?
Warte mal, ich gehe mal kurz...
Hier, jetzt, ne?
Okay, jetzt hat er wieder runtergedreht.
Guck mal, wie schnell die Temperatur runtergeht, wenn der Lüfter mal hochgegangen ist.
Okay, brechen wir ab.
Ne, der war auf jeden Fall cool genug.
Okay.
Ja, dann probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Moment, wie war das mit Windows und NFS jetzt?
Ich habe noch nie NFS benutzt unter Windows.
und man kann unter windows jetzt moment wenn dort seit wann hat windows einen
mount befehl ok das dass das das muss jetzt mal ausprobieren ob media volt wir
erstellen jetzt mal nfs services nfs settings enabled ok shares mama nur die ssd das ist das
einfaches client hausse lauter mörder fall system 12 2.168 punkt 0 24 komplette netz permissions
Weed right, Subtree check insecure.
Okay, meinetwegen.
Da guckst du, ja.
Was ist das? Feature?
Optional Features.
Ne.
Oh ja.
Was jetzt?
NFS.
SMB.
Services for NFS.
Client for NFS.
Was es hier alles gibt, oder, Windows?
Was ist das, hä?
Und nun?
Nein!
Es muss auch ohne Neustart gehen.
Und jetzt kann man angeblich einfach
mounten, oder wie?
Ah, Moment, das geht jetzt ja nicht.
Aha, Moment.
Mount.
Okay, wir haben nur einen Mount-Parameter.
Mount minus O, Anon.
Und jetzt?
Slash, Slash.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 1, 5, 2.
Slash.
Merger.
Z-Doppelpunkt.
Nein.
Das funzt schon immer nett.
Äh.
Ich bin in PowerShell, ja und, ist das ein Problem?
Muss ich in dieses hässliche
Da hin?
Ne
Gibt schon mal gar nicht
Sag mal, das ist doch irgendeine dumme
Irgendeine dumme
KI generierte Schrottseite hier, oder?
windows mount nfs
mons an und server ip-channel ja das habe ich doch gerade gemacht
cannot be processed because the parameter name is ambiguous
okay ich frage jetzt wie frag jetzt chat gpt wie das geht keine ahnung
was netz
I want to mount NFS
ja nein das geht doch nicht die lügen wieder
Das lügt wieder.
Ich habe das NFS-Feature installiert, ja.
Mount.exe soll ich callen
Ne, gibt's nicht
Alter, die lügen wieder
KI stellt's
Aber in CMD geht's doch auch nicht.
Haben wir doch gerade ausprobiert.
Da gibt's das gar nicht.
Was?
Registry?
What?
Service.
NFS.
Na was muss ich denn?
Was ist das hier überhaupt?
Hackerman-Shit oder was?
Was ist das?
Das sehe ich zum ersten Mal. Warum läuft das im Hintergrund?
Plan 9 Redirector Driver.
Okay, alles klar.
Das geht erst nach Reboot.
Okay, dann fick dich Windows.
Ich reboote jetzt.
Ich reboote bestimmt jetzt nicht.
Ganz bestimmt werde ich nicht rebooten jetzt.
Ich reboote jetzt nicht.
Dann machen wir das jetzt nicht.
Wisst ihr was? Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Ich habe eh keinen Bock auf
NFS unter
unter Windows.
Hast du eine Windows vor einem Jahr?
Aber da kriege ich keine 10 Gig drüber.
Ähm.
Ich aninstalle das jetzt einfach
und gucke es nie wieder an.
Warum auch immer dafür rebooted werden muss, ne?
Weiß man nicht so genau.
Don't restart.
Close.
Alles weg hier.
Alter.
Geh mal bloß weg.
Okay, gut.
also jetzt haben wir so eine baseline geschwindigkeit auf der auf der nass
kiste also wir kriegen hier ungefähr mit mergefs also sprich so auf die ssd
erstmal und dann auf die platte danach kriegen wir also 950 mb die sekunde oder
so was da braucht ein bisschen das ist aber wahrscheinlich irgendeine samba
magic und dann geht das wieder hoch
Aber wenn ich den Service gestartet hätte,
hätte der Mount-Profil immer noch nicht funktioniert.
Der hat ja gemeckert, dass irgendwie Minus O nicht geht.
Also so 950 MB
oder irgendwie sowas kriegen wir da drüber.
So, ähm...
Äh, was?
Raid 5 neu machen oder Online-Migration
durchlaufen lassen, um einen Disc zu entdauern.
90 Stunden ist erst mal 17%.
Oh ja, wenn es ein großes Raid 5 ist,
ist das ja normal.
Also ich würde die Erweiterung
durchlaufen lassen. Dafür hast du es ja letztendlich.
Du willst ja, dass es verfügbar bleibt.
Du solltest dir nur überlegen,
dass ein Raid 5 mit vielen
Festplatten meistens keine so gute Idee ist. Also wenn du jetzt ein RAID 5 hast mit, keine Ahnung,
8 25 TB Platten, dann ist die Chance, dass es in Rebuild überlebt bei meiner kaputten Platte,
relativ gering.
Okay, also jetzt haben wir hier Baseline Geschwindigkeit zu 950 MB die Sekunde.
Dann machen wir jetzt Power Off beim Open Media Vault.
Und legen jetzt einen neuen Container an.
Ach so.
Ha.
Ne.
Moment.
Eine Sache wollte ich auf dem Open Media Vault gerade noch ausprobieren.
Dann muss ich wieder einschalten.
Aber das geht ja glücklicherweise alles relativ geschwind.
Und zwar wollte ich nochmal ein Fio machen.
ähm,
SRV
hier hin aufs MergerFS.
Mal kurz gucken, wie schnell
der hier ist.
Wenn ich mit einem Benchmark auf die Disk gehe.
Okay, das ist nicht nur, das ist nicht
wirklich Samba. Guckt mal.
Das ist anscheinend normal, dass der erstmal langsam
anfängt und dann
schneller wird.
So als müsste erstmal irgendein
Cache volllaufen. Oder erstmal
irgendein Cache warmlaufen.
Und dann funktioniert's.
aber auf die geschwindigkeiten da können wir mit sambal nur träumen den speed da
können wir mit sambal nur träumen
ok zwischendurch droppt zwar ein bisschen runter immer whatever aber da
Da können wir summertechnisch nur träumen zum größten Teil.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal.
Jetzt machen wir das hier aus.
Power off.
Und jetzt erstellen wir uns einen LXC-Container.
Create. Container.
Passwort 123456789.
Top Secret Passwort.
Ah ne, ich brauch nen SSH-Key.
Das ist deutlich besser.
Äh, Pupp.
Das ist deutlich sinniger.
Kann ich mir nämlich auch direkt einloggen.
Ähm, okay.
Hostname ist mir wurscht.
Äh, ja, keine Ahnung.
Äh, LXC.
Nass.
So.
Ähm, Nesting.
Unprivileged Container.
Ähm.
Ich glaube, ich brauche
einen Privileged Container, Leute.
Weil.
Brauche ich einen Privileged Container?
Weil ich will ja irgendwelche Sachen
mounten. Ja, ich brauche einen Privileged Container.
Ich will ja MergerFS mitbenutzen.
Vom.
Vom Host. Also vom.
Von der Kiste unten drunter.
Weil ich denke mal, wir brauchen einen Privileged
container template debian 13 standard discs ja geben wir mal 16 gig und da
werden ja die verzeichnisse reingemontet
fünf cpu kurs sollte erstmal dicke reichen
das ist eine Sache, die müsste ich mir echt mal merken.
4.000,
4.600, 8192,
genau. So,
next.
Static, DHCP,
Static IPv6,
ja, so, okay.
Ähm,
192.168.2.153
kriegt er jetzt.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob das
frei ist.
Ja.
Static, DNS,
Finish.
Okay.
Nice.
Falsches Feld mit der IP?
Echt?
Oh, das war der Gateway.
Ups.
Ah.
Okay.
Äh
Achso
Slash24
Okay und wie kann ich jetzt hier
Ressourcen
Durchreichen
Das ging nur über
Das ging glaube ich nur über
So ein Spezialding
Proxmox Path
Through Directory LXC
Nicht GPU
Mount Host Directory
Into LXC
Ja genau das da
Also
Der LXC Container
host dir okay also work safe wir machen mal extra ordner mk dir worksafe lxc
lxc map nach
ähm
work
oder keine Ahnung
cash
ok
haben wir das?
ah da ist es, guck mal
ich find's ja cool, dass man das editieren kann im Webinterface
aber nicht anlegen kann im Webinterface
Und No Art Time ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Aber erstmal scheiß drauf, lassen wir.
Okay, starte das verdammte Spiel.
Sollte der jetzt nicht eigentlich starten?
Sollte ich jetzt hier nicht eigentlich was sehen?
Okay, SSH 122168
2.53
X SSH
Yes
Äh, Root
Oder Debian
Debian, oder?
Äh, Chat
Warum ist das jetzt gefreest?
Warum ist das hier oben gefreest?
Hast du Debian 13 als LXC genommen?
Ja
Ah
Moment
Das hat funktioniert da oben, habt ihr das gesehen?
Warum ist denn das so ultra langsam?
Irgendwelche DNS-Auflösung oder sowas?
Ich habe mir erst das Hakey hinterlegt.
Warum ist das denn so abfuck langsam?
Nesting aktivieren!
Stimmt!
Das war's!
Ich erinnere mich, das Problem hatten wir schon mal, gell?
Das Problem haben wir schon mal.
Genau.
Stop.
Options.
Features.
Nesting.
Yes.
Nimm ein OMV-Template.
Das ist ein LXC-Container.
um vm lxt container geht nur sehr halbherzig da sind update upgrade
Jawohl, gib ihm
Ja, jetzt kommt mein Endgegner
Samba-Config
So
Alles klar. Kommen wir
Rebooten nochmal schnell.
Das geht ja glücklicherweise
sauschnell bei LXC Containern. Da ist er schon wieder.
Guck.
Also. So.
Da sind wir. Wir haben jetzt hier unter
Slash Cache
Slash Cache haben wir die
SSD gemountet. Lass uns mal kurz
gucken. App Install
Hardtop Temux Fio
Lass uns mal gucken
wie schnell der ist, wenn ich
Raw auf die Platte schreibe.
Du müsst ja genauso schnell sein wie auf dem Host.
Das ist aber ziemlich schlecht, wenn du nur 100 MBit hast.
Das suckt.
Oh, der flutscht ja richtig.
Guck mal hier.
Seht ihr das?
Okay, jetzt geht er auf normale Geschwindigkeiten wieder.
Der flutscht ja richtig.
Guckt mal hier.
Flutsch, Flutsch Champ.
Okay, jetzt sind wir wieder bei normaleren Geschwindigkeiten.
Jetzt sind wir ziemlich langsam gerade.
Was ist da los?
Jetzt sind wir wieder schnell.
Also ich würde mal sagen, so im Durchschnitt ein Gig oder so.
Warum droppt denn das zwischendurch immer auf so langsame Werte?
Was ist denn da los?
SSD-Cache voll.
Ich habe das aber schon mal getestet mit vollem SSD-Cache.
Und die Festplatten, die haben so ungefähr 1,2 GB die Sekunde, wenn der Cache voll ist.
Aber ein Virtua FS kann es ja nicht liegen, weil der ist das erste Mal viel schneller.
Auch nicht.
Okay, whatever.
Die werden zu warm.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Das habe ich auch gerade gedacht, aber das glaube ich eigentlich nicht.
Sensors, gucken wir mal.
Nee.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Solange es nicht 65.261 Grad ist, ist alles kein Problem.
Aber hier 62 Grad, 61 Grad und so, das ist alles kein Ding.
Aber Chat, was ich jetzt nicht ganz verstehe, ist...
Das muss mir mal irgendjemand erklären.
Moment, schreibt das überhaupt auf die richtige SSD jetzt?
Schreibt das jetzt auf die richtige SSD?
Ähm.
Work, Save, LXC, ja macht das.
Das schreibt auf die richtige SSD.
Hä?
Okay, Chat, wir probieren jetzt mal was aus.
Wir machen jetzt das gleiche, mal auf dem Host auf die SSD.
ausbessert ist besser
na so viel geiler ist es auch nicht
Warum ist das so langsam?
Warum ist das so langsam? Was soll das hier? Anzeige
Ich schreibe auf den Mount, ja.
Ja, das muss was mit dem SSD-Cache zu tun haben.
Aber ist trotzdem dumm.
Da liegt es am Ende.
Ah!
Moment.
etc modprobe dzfs ok der zfsk ist schon ein bisschen oben
mount options und options kann ich selbst setzen per ja wieso was willst
denn für mount options setzen also a time und sowas bringt es jetzt ja nicht wirklich bei
datei die konstant geschrieben wird
naja schauen wir mal hecken muss weg ok ab install sam war
ohne scheiß heute sam barcon fix mein entgegner ich bin da richtig unfähig für ich kann mir das
immer nicht merken, wie das auszusehen hat.
Muss man bei SSDs nicht
Discard setzen in Proxmox?
Müssen muss man
das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoll,
das zu setzen, dass Sachen wieder freigegeben werden.
Was soll das denn sein?
Ich führe doch keine random Sachen da.
So, etc.
Samba, Samba, Conf.
Okay.
Erstmal einen ordentlichen Editor installieren.
Also, Samba, Samba, Conf.
Lass mal überlegen, ob ich das noch halbwegs hinkriege.
Comment, Home Directories, Browser will know.
Irgendwie so Funster-Kram noch.
Profiles, Printers.
Simple, Samba,
von 4-1-Share.
Okay, beste.
public share nicht public share wir müssen auch erstmal ein user anlegen ok public share user
also cash brausable yes cash brausable yes writeable yes guest ok read only no force user
Nobody. Okay, reicht das jetzt schon?
System.
CTL.
Restart. SMB.
SMB und NMB muss man
immer restarten, ne?
Dann muss ich doch SMBD. Ach, keine Ahnung.
Schauen wir mal. Was hältst du von Nano?
Abstand.
Okay, ich brauche doch einen User.
Okay.
Samba und Usergedöns. Alter.
smb wie ging das smb pass wd minus a max 123456 1 2 3 4 5 6 fällt to add entry for user max ok
warum warum
Okay, soll er nicht Max heißen?
Max 2.
Okay.
Das war falsch.
SMB Passwd.
Ich habe das doch richtig?
Hä?
Was hat der denn für Schmerzen?
Passwort zu kurz, meint ihr?
Okay, okay, ich gebe jetzt mal das...
Aber nee, nee, nee, das muss gehen.
Fail to add entry, was hat der denn?
Achso, ah, der User muss existieren
Ach, logisch
Äh, Leute
Add User oder User Add
Ich kann es mir nie merken
Was ist das, was dich alles abfragt?
User Add oder Add User
It's a low level utility
Es ist Add User
Add User
Yes
Okay
SMP
Okay, wunderbar
Seher Mord
Auf Cache
Okay, jetzt
Darf ich jetzt?
Äh
Oh Gott, Windows, Alter
Achso, Moment, das hier ist ja noch off
Das macht komische Sachen
Windows macht komische Dinger
Da sind wir, Leute
Public Share, da sind wir
Bam
Aha
Okay, guck dir mal, das ist schon ein bisschen schneller.
Wobei ich mir fast noch ein Ticken mehr erhofft hätte, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hätte mir so 1,1 erhofft.
1,2 vielleicht in Spitzenzeiten.
Aber das ist schon mal besser.
Ich weiß gar nicht, von was wir limitiert sind.
Sind wir jetzt limitiert von der SSD?
Sind wir limitiert von der Netzwerkkarte?
Theoretisch gehen noch so 100, 150 MB mehr.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es an Samba selbst liegt.
Oh, ist jetzt der SSD-Cache voll?
Und deswegen bricht es ein?
Jetzt ist bestimmt der SSD-Cache voll, hä?
Das ist nicht QLC.
Das ist ein 990 Pro.
Die hat SLC-Cache.
Und danach ist es...
Was ist das denn dann?
Oder ist das dann QLC?
Der andere Speicher?
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
TLC, genau.
TLC ist es.
Guck mal, jetzt hat es sich wieder gefangen, lustigerweise.
Nee, QLC ist das, oder?
QLC ist doch der billige Speicher.
Die haben doch, die haben doch
einen SLC-Cache und, und
die sind Q, das sind QLC-SSDs,
haben aber irgendwie einen SLC-Cache
oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber mit der Geschwindigkeit kann ich
leben, Leute, das ist okay.
Bisschen mehr hätte es auch sein können, aber es ist in Ordnung.
Muss man hier vielleicht noch sonst irgendwelche...
Wartet mal.
Muss man hier sonst vielleicht noch irgendwelche Caches oder so, Caching-Sachen ein- und ausschalten?
Hier irgendwie was?
Ja.
Puh.
Es ist okay so.
Gut.
Äh.
Dann wissen wir jetzt ja schon mal, wie man Samba-Shares einrichtet.
Ich bin da immer echt super planlos.
Also Samba ist für mich echt der Endgegner, ne?
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Samba-Sets?
Twerks oder so die man die man einstellen sollte
Warte mal ich muss mir diesen ich muss mir diesen ganzen Müll hier löschen das ist so unübersichtlich
blickt man wenigstens halbwegs durch
So, ich hoffe ich habe jetzt nicht zu viel gelöscht
Restart
Ne, Jumbo Frames meine ich
Public Share, ne passt
Ähm
Gibt es irgendwelche
Okay, Samba
Performance Tuning
Ich glaube Async soll man noch setzen, oder?
Async sollte man irgendwie noch setzen
Wenn ich das richtig mit der Kopf hab
Enhanced Samba
Äh
Alter, was ist das für eine Fake Sache
SMB-Con
Tuning
Es gab so 1-2 Optionen, die man setzen sollte
Im Multithread ist das doch standardmäßig schon.
Wie heißt das nicht?
Async?
Async.io?
Oder AIO oder sowas?
AIO!
AIO.
Genau, das meine ich.
Das soll man setzen.
Genau.
Das da.
Wir fragen hier.
AI-Modus.
Das ist alles.
Read Raw, yes.
Right.
Das ist aktiviert.
Das hier brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
SMB-Version.
Multichannel brauchen wir nicht.
version 3 sagen wir mal dass das summer version 3 verwendet das macht aber windows
doch eh schon standardmäßig oder ja so was hier
was hier ob wir hoffen dass die ei nicht lügt ja wie start okay das scheint schon mal funktioniert
zu haben die titel und jetzt ich würde sagen ein unterschied zu vorher sogar eher noch ein
ticken schlechter die multi channel bringt nichts das bringt ja nur was bei
mehreren netzwerken
beziehungsweise mehreren netzwerken oder jedoch glaube mehrere mehreren
netzwerken bringen das was laut red hat soll man server max protokoll komplett
löschen ja okay aber das macht also macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen
unterschied und das hier das kann man sie im endeffekt auch sparen das hat
auch keinen großen unterschied gemacht okay zack f5 bm
was richtig performance bringen würde wenn samba so eine art compression hätte
Ja, aber Samba 1 wird Windows nicht verwenden.
Also das hier können wir klicken.
So, und jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie installiert man Merger?
Merger FS.
Unter Debian.
Warte mal.
Box, Mox, LXC, Merger FS.
Wie funzt das richtig?
Ich will kein Snap Raid.
Okay, hier gibt es
anscheinend eine Anleitung.
Hä? Was?
Hä?
Nee, nee.
Ich will nicht MergerOS auf dem Host installieren.
Use.
Es geht bestimmt
irgendwie.
Okay.
wir gucken mal kurz bei github hier gibt es das neueste merger fs als debian package irgendwo
bookworm bullseye trixie amd 64 copy link
apt install zack merger fs yes
Okay, jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, wie man das hier richtig setupt.
Merger FS Setup.
Setup and Configuration.
Das will ich nicht so wirklich.
Ah hier, Merger FS, MNT, genau.
Genau.
So.
Also MergerFS, im Prinzip will ich eigentlich nur
Cache
auf
MNT. So.
Device not found.
Mod. Moment, ich bin ja in einem Container.
Das Funds zu Schornament, das muss ich ja
auf dem Host
machen.
Ähm.
Ich muss das durchreichen.
Wartet mal.
Ich muss...
Warte mal.
Fuße.
Dev Fuße.
Das da muss ich durchreichen an den Container.
Dass das funktioniert.
Resources.
Device Path Through.
Dev Fuße.
Waren wir einfach mal so und gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Dev.
Dev Fuße.
Aha, hat funktioniert.
So, MNT.
Bio.
Das dürfte jetzt lahm sein,
weil ich noch keine gescheiten Optionen gesetzt habe.
Okay.
Ja, geht eigentlich.
Okay, unmount.
Schauen wir nochmal.
Ähm, so, ich will cache.
Jetzt brauch ich mal
IO irgendwas.
Path.
Hier, das da will ich haben.
Default.
Default Path to RW.
Wie gibt man das an?
So?
Werke FS, use options.
Wie gibt man da die Options an?
Setup.
Minus O, oder?
Okay.
Gucken wir mal.
jetzt sollten wir hier
also wenn ich jetzt aber hier sage
minus O und gebe was an, was es
nicht gibt, dann mag er nicht.
Okay.
Oh, ich habe jetzt fünfmal drüber gemountet. Lull.
Okay, so.
MNT, Fio, Bäm.
Schauen wir mal.
Jetzt müssen wir noch einen Summershare machen, klar
Aber der SSD-Cache ist doch nie im Leben so schnell aufgebraucht
Leute
Der SSD-Cache ist irgendwo
Bei
Keine Ahnung, 120 GB oder so
Also das ist jetzt schon eklig langsam
Oder auch nicht
Das weiß ich nicht so genau
Ob es langsam ist oder nicht
Aber da ist ja die Open Media Vault
Vm schneller
Monk HW
Warum ist das der Fall?
Sucked
Dann
ETC
Samba
Samba Conf
Cash
ja MNT einfach
Public Share 2
beste Benahmung
Restart
Public Share 2
Naja
Also es ist insgesamt
ein bisschen schneller wie die Open Media Vault
VM, aber eigentlich zu vernachlässigen,
oder?
Also eigentlich kein richtiger Unterschied.
Was ich mit MergeFS mache,
ich habe
eine Festplatte, ich habe eine Magnet-Festplatte
und ein
SSD-Rate 1 und ich will neue
Daten,
die geschrieben werden, erstmal auf die SSD
packen und dann
nach und nach wegmoven auf die Platte,
so dass ich schön schnell auf die
Disk schreiben kann.
Also
schön schnell auf Samba Share schreiben kann.
Okay Leute, ganz im Ernst,
der Performance
Unterschied zwischen
der
Samba Kiste
auf Open Media Vault
oder dem LXC Container
ist also
nicht
wirklich ein Unterschied.
Macht keinen Unterschied
Das ist so gering
Das sind vielleicht 50 MB
Oder so Unterschied im Durchschnitt
Ich glaube dafür
Dann bleibe ich bei einer Open Media Vault
Vm
Wenn es nur die paar MB
Unterschied sind
Ich habe mir ja noch ein paar
So 100, 150 MB
Mehr ehrlich gesagt versprochen
Aber vielleicht kann man noch ein bisschen
An der Netzwerkkarte tunen
Oder wir könnten noch mal gucken
Ob das an der SSD
Vielleicht liegt
Jaja es ist beide das gleiche
Deswegen es sollte
ist, also vom OS her
sollte es da eigentlich nicht viel Unterschied geben.
Aber da ist mir das einfachere,
die einfachere Handhabung von
Open Media Vault lieber.
Also Chat, wisst ihr, was wir nochmal probieren
könnten? Nur um
mal auszuschließen, ne?
Um mal auszuschließen, dass es an
Ich mach das mal aus
Um mal auszuschließen, dass es an der SSD liegt
Wir nehmen mal
Aus dem ZFS Pool
Eine SSD raus
Wie macht man das?
ZFS Detach
Zpool
Detach
Work
Und jetzt
Def
Disk
Buy ID
Und jetzt
Nehmen wir hier die
Samsung
Hier die 2TB
Samsung nehmen wir raus
Zpool
Status
So und jetzt ist nur noch eine
Hier drin oder?
Genau so jetzt haben wir hier ein
Mirror wo eine
Wobei jetzt ist das kein Mirror mehr sondern ein einzelnes Laufwerk
So und jetzt können wir mal hier sagen
MKFS
XFS
Uff
Ähm
Und jetzt mounten wir das um
Jetzt sagen wir ihm
Dass sein Mountpoint
Ähm
Ach das kann, ach das darf ich gar nicht ändern
Aha
Okay, weil ich ja, okay, dann
Mounten wir das jetzt, erste Mal, Mount
Nach
Das da wird gemountet nach
MNT
Jetzt haben wir hier nochmal ein FIO drauf, ob das jetzt irgendwie
Ein großer Unterschied ist zwischen ZFS
Oder direkt auf die SSD
Okay, das ist schon mal deutlich
Schneller direkt auf die SSD
Aber wie gesagt, der Cache ist ja auch noch
Nicht aufgebraucht
Aber guckt mal, jetzt wenn der Cash aufgebraucht ist, jetzt dippt es auch nicht mehr unter 1000.
Seht ihr das?
Also, ein bisschen Performance einboosten haben wir durch die ganze ZFS-Geschichte schon.
Cash 2.
Ne, wir machen jetzt einfach hier nochmal.
Ähm.
MNT.
Genau, jetzt hat sich das hier so.
Jetzt können wir das nochmal starten.
Und jetzt sollte ich eigentlich genau das gleiche wiederbekommen.
Hängen beide SSTs vielleicht an denselben PCI-Lanes?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das eine ist 2x2 und das andere ist 2x3.
Wie soll das auch funktionieren, wenn das an den gleichen PCI-Lanes hängt?
Da müsste ja noch irgendein Switch oder so davor sein.
Ja, ja, also schneller als XFS geht es nicht mehr.
Das ist mir auch klar. Das will ich auch nicht verwenden.
Nur mal zum Ausprobieren.
Cash?
Pio?
Mal hier drauf schreiben.
Äh.
Was macht das da gerade?
Was zum Teufel macht das gerade da?
Es ist ja voll am Abspacken gerade.
Wie dem auch sei.
Merger FS
nach MNT.
Restart Samba.
Wollen wir mal.
Ähm.
Chat.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Warum ist hier schon eine Datei?
Achso, weil ich die gerade
Weil das gerade durch meinen FIO-Test
Angelegt wurde
You don't have permissions
Okay
CRMOD777-R
MNT
Oder Cache
Jetzt habe ich Rechte
Oh, jetzt warten wir mal kurz ab
Bis es wieder seinen Boost da bekommt
Also Chat, jetzt bin ich komplett verwirrt.
Ah, nee.
Hä?
Warum ist das jetzt sogar noch langsamer als ZFS?
Ich, ich, keine Ahnung, ich blick's nicht
Chat, ich blick nicht mehr durch
Das ist mir zu hoch
Das, das
Ich check's nicht mehr
Das wird jetzt eigentlich schneller sein
Auf XFS
Okay, wir machen nochmal eine Sache
Ja, in Spitzen ist es
Schön schnell, aber dann droppt es halt gleich wieder runter
Hä?
Okay, wir machen eine Sache nochmal hier
Unmount
MNT
Achso, ja
System CTL
Stop
Merge FS
Ich maute das jetzt einfach nur komplett mit Default.
Okay.
Restart.
Muss ich eigentlich NMB restarten?
Ach, da guck an.
Jetzt ist es tatsächlich ein bisschen schneller.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich so die Geschwindigkeit, die ich mir so er...
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Die ich mir so erhofft habe, ja.
So 1,1 G oder sowas.
Ich checke aber nicht, was es für Probleme hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich denke nicht, was es für Probleme hat.
Mit meinen Mount Options sollte es sogar langsamer sein jetzt als mit den anderen Mount Options.
Ich glaube, da wird es mal Zeit für einen systematischen Test jetzt.
Also jetzt nicht jetzt, sondern in Zukunft, dass man wirklich...
Alter, so mal Ausschlussverfahren so, ja?
Ich mache eine RAM-Disk dran und dann gucken wir mal, wie schnell er ist.
Also das ist schon weird.
Ja, so sieht es wahrscheinlich aus bei mir, dein systematischer Test.
Hast du schon recht.
jetzt muss ich hier gerade nochmal
einen FIO-Test machen
ich meine, was immer
ein ganz guter Test mit FIO ist, eigentlich ist
für SSDs, wenn man parallele Jobs
hat, ja, weil parallele Jobs
lasten halt die SSD, wie man
hier sieht, ja, schon
deutlich besser aus als einzelne
Write-Aufgaben
jetzt dreht übrigens die
CPU gerade richtig krass hoch, guck mal
Da flutscht die SSD richtig jetzt, ne?
Mit Parallel und Write.
Was man übrigens jetzt auch sehen müsste,
wenn ich das kopiere und nochmal...
Moment, kann ich nicht einfach zwei Sachen kopieren?
Hier, das da.
Copy.
VMs.
Stream.
Ich kopiere zwei Sachen.
Guck.
Und jetzt kriegen wir
1,
1,12
MB durch.
Ja.
Da wird das besser ausgelastet.
Vielleicht haben wir doch
irgendwie so ein SSD-Bottleneck aus
irgendwelchen... Was hat der denn für
Probleme, Alter?
Das ist doch alles nicht normal.
Oder liegt's doch an der Netzwerkkarte?
Der ist jetzt ja vorne am abkacken.
Okay, machen wir nochmal aus.
Gehen wir nochmal direkt
auf die SSD ohne Merger-FS.
Äh.
Chat?
Sollte er jetzt nicht beides kopieren?
Oder muss man das wirklich so machen,
dass er beides kopiert?
Also so richtig
100%ig glücklich bin ich damit noch nicht.
Okay, Chat.
Ich habe jetzt noch eine Idee, was ich mal ausprobieren will.
Guck mal.
Wir haben doch hier eben den Netzwerktreiber.
Ich remove nochmal meinen Netzwerktreiber.
Jetzt darf ich bloß nicht rebooten, bevor ich nicht den neuen wieder drinne habe.
Guck mal, wir haben doch ASPM ein- und ausgeschaltet eben.
Äh, AMPS, ASPM.
So.
EKMS.
Makefile.
Ja.
So, was ist denn, wenn ich diese ganzen Energiespar-Dinger einfach nochmal einschalte und es dann mit der anderen Netzwerkkarte teste, nicht von meinem Windows-PC aus, sondern von meiner Linux-Kiste aus?
Debian, SICK.
Install.
Hast du die Möglichkeit, Jumbo Frames zu nutzen über Netzwerk?
Können, könne ich.
Will ich aber nicht.
Ich will mein lokales Netzwerk nicht auf Jumbo Frames umstellen.
Da muss dann so viel Zeug das unterstützen und sowas.
Ist mir nix.
So, und jetzt rebooten wir mal.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, dann sollte das jetzt wieder langsam sein.
Desktop,
IPerf,
IPerf 3
minus C, 1.21,
2.151 gleich. Das sollte
wieder langsam sein.
Was supportet bitte keine Jumbo-Framen?
Das muss ich dann überall umstellen.
Da muss ich das an meinem Router umstellen,
zu dem Device, wo das zum Switch geht.
Ich hab da Raspberry Pis dran,
weiß ich gar nicht, ob die das können.
Das ist mir, also ganz ehrlich,
das ist mir zu viel Akt,
auf Jumbo Frames umzustellen.
Oh, Chat.
Ich hab
doofes Gefühl, wenn er noch nicht wieder da ist.
Ah, da ist er wieder.
Oh, nochmal Glück gehabt.
I perf 3 minus S.
So, jetzt sollte es wieder langsam sein, ne?
Ja.
Okay, es ist wieder lahm.
Es ist wieder lahm.
Also lahm, in Anführungsstrichen lahm
Und in die andere Richtung.
Die andere Richtung ist es gar nicht so lahm.
Das ist schon merkwürdig, oder?
Ich teste jetzt mal, wie schnell ich bin
zu meiner anderen 10-Gig-Kiste.
Auch nicht so geil, oder?
Aber immerhin etwas stabiler.
Ja, das ist stabil.
So muss das sein.
Jetzt probieren wir das mal aus.
Alperf 3.
also gegen dieses Geschwanke
kann man mit der Netzwerkkarte wohl nichts machen.
Aber was witzig ist,
gegen meine Linux-Kiste
habe ich mit Stromsparmodus keine so großen Drops.
Guck mal.
Von der Linux-Kiste zur anderen Linux-Kiste keine großen Drops.
Von der Windows-Kiste
Äh, Moment
Richtig
Drops
Ich kann keine
YouTube-Videos gerade machen
Ich bin da
Ich muss erstmal wieder
Kopfmäßig das alles auf die Reihe kriegen
Hast du gecheckt, ob das überhaupt eingeschaltet ist?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass das eingeschaltet ist, weil ich habe jetzt wieder diese Geschwindigkeits-Drops von Windows.
Guck hier, 7,2 irgendwas.
Wie kann man das gescheit checken?
ETH-Tool?
Check if ASPM is enabled network.
Oder muss ich dann wieder LSPCI
Okay, LSPCI
Seht ihr hier irgendwas?
Von ASPM
Chatge
Ach ne, Minus VV muss ich machen, gell
Für mehr Verbs
Ich glaube das dauert sogar noch
Ich glaube da muss man noch länger
Grab
ASPM Support
Linux
Da gab es noch so einen schönen Grab
Dafür, hier
Ne, ne, das bringt mir ja nichts
Ich will ja wissen, was für ein Netzwerkgerät
Dazu
Hier, ASP-ER ist enabled
Ist eingeschaltet
Du hast immer noch Potenzial, kein Corporate-Hamsterzeug zu machen.
Was soll das denn heißen?
Hä?
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Du meinst, ich müsste nicht arbeiten gehen, ich könnte ja Vollzeit-YouTube machen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das halte ich geistig nicht aus.
Wenn ich darauf angewiesen bin und was machen muss, obwohl ich keinen Bock habe, heute was zu machen.
Nee, das ist, also ohne Mist, das wäre mir zu große psychische Belastung, das hauptberuflich zu machen.
Was macht denn mein Job? Der jobbt.
Da läuft's.
Ja, also ich werde auf jeden Fall wieder YouTube-Videos machen.
Ich werde nie ganz aufhören.
Aber aktuell kriege ich das gerade nicht auf die Reihe.
Der Job ist ja auch Forced.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber wenn es einem da mal schlecht geht und man keinen Bock hat,
dann kann man auch mal ein bisschen Gaspedal rausnehmen.
Und bei YouTube musst du halt, du musst produzieren, wenn du davon lebst.
Also das wird glaube ich oft unterschätzt, was für ein psychischer Druck es ist, Vollzeit-Content-Creator zu sein.
Ne, ich spiele gerade kein Battlefield.
Ich hab Battlefield 6 gekauft, aber nur nicht gespielt.
Solche Themen wie das wären eine Bereicherung für YouTube.
Welche Themen wie das?
Dass ich zu dumm bin, meine Netzwerkkarte richtig zu benutzen, oder was?
Hast du schon auf Secure Boot umgestellt?
Ja.
Also ich glaube, was richtig gut auf YouTube ankommen würde, sind so ein paar abgedrehte Sachen.
Also auf lange Sicht, ja.
Sowas wie beispielsweise mein PXE-Server.
Hab ich euch das schon mal...
Hab ich...
Leute, das hab ich euch heute ja noch gar nicht gezeigt.
Das muss mindestens einmal pro Stream sein, oder?
Guck mal, wie nice ich das gemacht hab hier mit PXE.
wir erstellen jetzt mal eine vm in proxim das habe ich jetzt gemacht oder wir stellen jetzt
mal hier temp vm erstellen man davor einen box ok wir installieren keine us drauf wir lassen
hier alles default alles die fall war mal kremer agent vielleicht noch an alles die fall alles
default gegeben dem ding 3 cpu kerne next memory 2 oder mama mama 8 gig next
standardmäßig netzwerk sonst war es nächst jetzt passt mal auf massive was
jetzt
Ah, ich bin dumm.
Ich habe vergessen, meine Festplatte zu anlocken.
Dann kann das natürlich nicht gehen.
Okay, nochmal.
Create VM.
Äh, Temp VM.
Immer Anwenderfehler.
So, wir installieren nichts drauf.
Äh, QEMU Agent.
Aktivieren Disk.
Klassener Standardmäßig.
Drei CPU-Kerne.
Memory.
Äh, 8 Gig.
Kriegt das Ding.
alles gut, Netzwerk, zack,
Finish. So, und jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich hab nix da drauf installiert
und ich hab auch keine ISO
eingelegt oder sonst irgendwas
und ich kann jetzt, wenn ich die VM starte,
wenn das dann nochmal irgendwann fertig ist,
wenn ich die VM starte, guckt mal, was
jetzt Nices passiert. Ich muss
nix machen und er bootet
in den PXE.
Guck mal, also
erstens ist das der schönste PXE-Boot-Screen,
den ihr bisher gesehen habt, oder?
Keiner hat so einen nicen PXE-Boot-Screen wie wir hier, Chat.
Ist das ein KI-Bild? Ich weiß, ich weiß, das ist ein KI-Bild.
Aber es ist ein nices KI-Bild.
So, guck mal, jetzt kann ich hier direkt PXE booten.
Ich habe hier zig Möglichkeiten. Ich kann lokal booten.
Ich kann mir die NetConfig angucken von dem Ding.
Ich kann NetBoot XYZ booten, Sachen, die ich nicht lokal habe.
ZFS-Boot-Menü, CloneZilla, Rescue, CD, Rescue CD mit ZFS.
Ein Linux Mint, ein CacheOS habe ich am Start.
Und einen Debian Installer und einen eigenen Installer.
So, und jetzt passt mal auf.
So schnell wie über meinen PXE-Server habt ihr noch nie eine lokale Debian-Installation gesehen.
So, Install.
PP-Hintergrund wäre angebracht.
Ne, den haben wir schon an anderen Stellen.
Passt mal auf hier.
So, Setup.
Wir wollen Debian Stable installieren auf die erste Harddisk mit diesem Hostnamen.
Bam!
Blazing Defast. Und zack, Debian ist installiert.
Ist das nicht pock?
So schnell habt ihr das noch nie gesehen.
Schnellste Debian-Installation aller Zeiten.
Und was noch viel besser ist,
wir kriegen jetzt sogar gleich die IP angezeigt
hier auf dem Prompt und können uns dahin
connecten. Guck.
Hier. IP.
Okay, das Connecten funzt nicht, weil ich mein SSH-Key
nicht da hab.
In SSH-Key
hab ich das nicht hinterlegt. Okay.
Aber von der Theorie her, ihr seht,
dass
das Ding theoretisch erreichbar wäre.
Ich habe meinen SSH-Key noch nicht auf meinem PXE-Server hinterlegt.
Meinen SSH-Key von der neuen Linux-Kiste.
Aber das ist doch mal nice, oder?
Das geht alles über meinen selbst aufgebauten PXE-Server.
Stopp.
So, muss man jetzt erstmal zeigen.
Ist das Cloud oder On-Prem?
Das ist On-Prem.
ähm
aber die Sachen
wie es installiert wird
ist
also ich weiß jetzt nicht wie es beispielsweise
Hetzner macht unter der Haube
aber ich wette das ist sehr ähnlich
zu dem wie Hetzner das macht
die werden garantiert auch irgendein Image
booten und auf die Platte
dd'en und dann laufen 3-4 Cloud
Innit Sachen und dann ist die Kiste da
ich glaube
dass das sehr sehr ähnlich ist zu dem wie das beispielsweise
auch Hetzner macht
bist du cloud devops experte aws für aws
ich habe mit aws habe ich nichts zu tun ich bin der fox experte könnte man das
vielleicht nennen google wobei ich bei meinem neuen job kein der fox titel mehr
Beim letzten war ich Senior DevOps Engineer.
Immerhin, ich bin ja schon alt genug.
Jetzt bin ich Linux Engineer.
Ich werde aber demnächst, wird das gewechselt,
demnächst bin ich Senior Site Reliability Engineer.
Warum, weiß ich nicht.
Weil sich mein Arbeitgeber ausgedacht hat,
die alten Jobbezeichnungen sind zu oldschool.
Wir brauchen was Neues. Ich mach genau das
gleiche wie vorher. Aber
ich heiß dann Senior
Site Reliability Engineer.
Was auch immer, ich hab's mir nicht ausgedacht.
Ich nehm's zur Kenntnis.
Lassen wir dann einfach so.
Oh ja, da
hab ich richtig Bock drauf, mal wieder Jobreviews
zu machen.
Wie findet man eigentlich raus, ob man
okay verdient?
Es ist in der Tat
gar nicht so einfach.
Es gibt...
Es gibt so ein paar Seiten, da müsst ihr jetzt aber auch gucken, ich benutze das zu selten,
wo man so ganz grob Durchschnittsgehälter pro Branche, pro Region sehen kann.
Aber das ist in der Tat nicht einfach.
Ja, und ich habe da auch gut reden.
Frankfurt Finanzbranche
ist glaube ich in Deutschland
der
top bezahlende
quasi Region und Branche.
Es muss ja auch
einen Vorteil haben, dass man sich
jeden Tag in Frankfurt
die ganzen fertigen Leute am Hauptbahnhof
angucken muss.
Oh, ich muss meine Pille noch nehmen hier.
Der Tee ist irgendwie komisch.
Na gut Leute, was sagt ihr denn als Fazit heute zum Stream?
Lohnt sich das, in einem LXC-Container zu machen?
Oder sollte ich einfach bei der Open Media Vault VM bleiben?
Ganz ehrlich, ich tendiere, ich bleibe einfach bei der Open Media Vault VM.
Weil der Performance-Unterschied ist nahezu nicht existent.
Und OMV ist vom Handling her einfacher.
Du würdest Serverless Managed Service machen.
Ah, also du meinst quasi auf meinem NAS soll ich Serverless machen.
Das klingt logisch, ja.
Das ist ja auch Serverless, das ist ja auch ein NAS.
Geht das?
Es kommt darauf an, was du unter Serverless meinst.
Wenn du meinst, sowas wie Cloud Functions und sowas, das geht auch auf einem NAS-Lokal, ja.
Aber Serverless-Lokal klingt halt ein bisschen doof.
Das geht, das geht.
Ja, ja.
Kannst du machen.
So gibt es beispielsweise OpenFARs und solche Dinger.
Mit Kubernetes.
Aber Kubernetes ohne Container geht natürlich nicht, weil Kubernetes ein Container-Orchestrator ist.
Da kannst du schlecht ohne Container irgendwas machen.
Ich meine, du kannst mittlerweile, du kannst in Kubernetes theoretisch auch VMs laufen lassen.
Aber das ist dann unter der Haube wahrscheinlich auch nur eine Node, wo das KVM-Device in Container weitergeleitet wird.
Und darin dann irgendwelche VMs gestartet werden.
Ist das nicht teuer in der Cloud?
Ja, also ich sage jetzt mal, ich glaube nicht, dass die meisten Leute, die mit der Idee Kostenersparnis als Hauptmotivation in die Cloud gehen, dass das was wird.
Also wenn Kostenersparnis die einzige Motivation ist, in die Cloud zu gehen, dann ist es wahrscheinlich der falsche Move.
Es kann Kosten sparen, aber nur in speziellen Fällen.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du was super skalierbares brauchst und halt richtig, richtig große Fluktuationen hast, was Userzahlen angeht, ja, so nach dem Motto, du hast drei Tage die Woche so fünf User und drei Tage die Woche hast du, was weiß ich, zwei Millionen User oder sowas.
Ja, da kann sich das durchaus lohnen, aber normalerweise würde ich sagen, hast du wenig Kostenersparnis.
Du laberst hier als solche.
Du bist ein
FinOps-Practitioner.
GG.
Chat, any FinOps-Enjoyers hier?
Was für ein Ding?
Ja, FinOps-Practitioner ist er.
So, Leute.
Ich muss jetzt was futtern.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Was, Max Frankfurt ist nicht so schlimm, war erst in Kassel, Bischofshöhe.
Da war ich noch nie.
Aber ich muss sagen, Berlin Hauptbahnhof war auch nicht so viel besser.
Also Berlin Hauptbahnhof wurde ich direkt an daheim erinnert.
Das erste, was ich in Berlin erlebt habe,
erstmal, dass es schwierig ist zu finden, auf welcher Seite man raus muss vom Bahnhof.
Aber als ich dann die richtige Seite gefunden habe,
kommt mir irgendein Penner entgegen und hustet mich direkt an.
Direkt in der Tür noch.
Ich habe gesagt, ey, es ist wie daheim.
Habe ich hier wieder einen vor?
Aber Leute, jetzt muss ich was essen.
Ich habe hier neben mir
Sandwich Maker
Toastbrot liegen. Und das ist schon ein bisschen kühl.
Das muss jetzt mal weg.
Sonst schmeckt das nicht mehr.
Ich werde bei der Open Media Vault
vor allem bleiben.
Power off.
Und hier machen wir aus.
Du warst heute
14 Stunden im Zug.
Alter.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass du da
halb dead gebisst.
und morgen ist montag da muss er klar wieder arbeiten warst du beruflich irgendwie ausbildung
schulung sonst wie unterwegs in deutschland oder oder war das eher privatvergnügen dies
bell vieles ich gucke wie es genau nicht wie gesagt ich bin da gerade kopfmäßig nicht so
frei für YouTube-Sachen.
Aber mit Bahn
und Verspätung geht das schon.
Bist du offen für Kooperation?
Äh,
wie, inwiefern? Also,
auf YouTube erst mal nicht, weil
da mache ich ja gerade nichts.
Nee, erstmal nicht.
Erstmal muss ich wieder Videos machen.
Battlefield Stream irgendwann Noobs bashen.
Das Problem bei der Sache ist,
dass ich gerade in Battlefield 6,
weil ich noch nie gespielt habe,
selbst der Ultra-Noob bin.
Aber ich meine, immerhin haben wir letztens gesehen,
meine Reaction-Time ist immer noch
top für mein Alter.
Wenigstens das ist nicht das Problem.
142 Millisekunden
äh 152 Millisekunden
mit 42
Millisekunden genau mit
in Jahre also mit
42 Jahre alt
das ist schon ganz okay
kannst du mit der ganzen
Truppe Mario Kart spielen
welche Truppe
Mario Kart hätte ich tatsächlich
ich irgendwie Bock drauf.
Ich habe aber keine
Switch 2.
Aber auf Mario Kart
hätte ich echt mal wieder Bock.
Bei welcher Versicherung
arbeitest du?
Das wird nicht
geleakt jetzt.
Achso, mit den Leuten meint ihr.
Nee, da kenne ich
niemanden von. Das Einzige, den ich kenne, ist
hier der Solution.
Da kenne ich niemanden von. Außerdem habe ich nicht genug
Zuschauer.
Und ich
habe nicht mal eine Switch 2.
Genau.
Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Gibt es den M-Core eigentlich noch?
Macht er noch Videos?
Ne.
Zedke.
Welche Versicherung würdest du denn empfehlen?
Ich kann euch nur sagen, wo ich beispielsweise meine Krankenversicherung habe.
Aber das wird euch wahrscheinlich auch nichts bringen.
Naja, ganz ehrlich, Check24 halte ich wenig von.
Also zum Vergleichen ja, wobei ihr da auch genau gucken müsst.
Weil oftmals sieht es dann nur so billig aus, weil da irgendwelche kurzfristigen Sonderkonditionen drin sind.
Aber über Check24 irgendwas kaufen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Gibt es GSS?
Habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr gehört.
Das gab auch mal die Rheinfelsquelle.
Keine Ahnung, ob es die noch gibt.
Was macht eigentlich?
Moment mal.
Ei, der Friseur, der heißt ja nicht mehr so auf Twitch.
Da heißt er irgendwie anders jetzt, ne?
Genau, da heißt es jetzt irgendwie so.
auf YouTube und...
Nee, der Friese heißt ja noch gar nicht mehr auf Twitch.
Der heißt doch gar nicht mehr so.
Der heißt doch jetzt irgendwie anders.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab's vergessen.
Der hat doch irgendeinen anderen Namen jetzt.
Und streamt manchmal irgendwelche Weeb-Gacha-Games.
Cashew-S.
Du bist bis jetzt erstaunlich weit gekommen, nur manche Programme wollen ja zurecht wieder Rockstar Launcher, aber so weit habe ich es noch nie von Windows weg geschafft.
Das ist gut. Du hast, finde ich, mit CacheOS auch eine gute Wahl getroffen, was Einstiegsfreundlichkeit angeht.
Klar gibt es welche, die sind noch einsteigerfreundlicher, aber da bist du wenigstens schon mal auf dem richtigen Betriebssystem und kannst sagen, I use Arch, by the way.
Ich weiß, bei welcher Versicherung du bist.
Da bin ich auch.
Okay.
Dann.
Muss ich ja gar nichts sagen.
Dann weißt du ja schon Bescheid.
Okay, Leute.
Jetzt gehe ich einfach was fordern.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart. Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.